Oi, meu nome é Katy Beslado
sou a diretora de estratégia quântica da IBM
e de pesquisa em aplicações. Estou aqui para dissipar
o máximo de mitos sobre computação quântica
possível em sessenta segundos.
Os computadores quânticos são absolutamente reais
e temos dispositivos na nuvem da IBM agora que qualquer pessoa pode acessar.
Sim, mas apenas para certas coisas em que eles são realmente bons
como matemática super complexa, do tipo que o universo usa,
mas se você quer fazer planilhas ou enviar e-mail, use
o seu PC.
Sim, teoricamente, mas não
tão cedo. Ninguém faz um computador bom o suficiente para fazer isso
ainda. No futuro previsível estamos no caminho certo
e quando chegarmos lá vamos mudar a forma como protegemos
as informações.
Completamente falso. Os computadores quânticos
são fundamentalmente diferentes
e usam as leis da natureza para processar informações.
A IA de hoje roda em bons e velhos dispositivos clássicos,
mas acreditamos que eles vão se unir no futuro.
Não é verdade. Temos um tremendo ecossistema
de startups, academia, laboratórios nacionais e parceiros da indústria que
usam nossos dispositivos todos os dias.
Não. Computação inspirada no quântico existe há
muito tempo e roda em dispositivos clássicos. Eles
nunca vão cumprir a promessa da computação quântica.
Se você quer computação quântica de verdade, você tem que fazer isso com quantum
computers reais